okay so here's where we're going to
begin um how long does it take to return
to the ground
so as i mentioned in my sort of clue my
little hint
i'm going to redefine everything i'm
going to say let's let's just forget
about what happened before
because i i'm asking the question how
long does it take to return to the
ground
so from my maximum height i'm viewing
that as time
zero so that's my new initial condition
and i'm going to call that my origin
and the downward journey is going to be
in the positive direction so you can see
there
i'm saying positive is now downward and
here's my initial condition when times
zero
i start at the origin which is the
maximum height and then my velocity is
also
zero because at the maximum height i'm
not moving that's why it's the maximum
height
now what this means is just just be
mindful right my destination
returning to the ground is going to be
in the positive direction
and i already know how far it's going to
be
from the original question right i'm
going to have to travel
32 and a half meters back toward the
ground but it'll be
positive 32.5 because i'm regarding
downward
as positive okay so with that in mind
what is our what's our force equation
going to look like what is our
acceleration equation
going to look like this is what i wrote
down okay
now just think about this and how
similar it is to the original
acceleration equation we had the
original acceleration equation
had a minus uh there because uh gravity
was working against us
so it was fighting and that's why you
can see it's negative against
the direction that we're moving in but
now that i've thought of positive as
downward
gravity is downward too so therefore
gravity should be
positive so that's why it's a positive
10 and the minus a fifth of v
is the same resistance from the medium
that we got earlier
so that's the first thing if you're
watching along
and you didn't have the same
acceleration equation
then i'm gonna ask you to pause the
video and um give it a go from here and
see if you get a different answer i
suspect some of the answers that were
wildly different
is because we didn't even start from the
same point
okay so that's the first comment and
then my next thing is
okay um at this point in my original
question in the first question i had to
choose a form for acceleration
that would help me answer the original
question which was what is y
in terms of v what is the displacement
vertically in terms of the velocity now
for that reason if you recall what we
chose was v
dv dy that is a way to express the
vertical acceleration
but in this case i'm asking a question
about time
right i'm not trying to get towards this
this displacement
thing this y value i already know what
the final y is going to be
it's going to be 32.5 so i'm not going
to choose v
dvdy for this i need something which
includes time
being that we've got velocity over here
so i'm gonna have to do some integration
with respect to v
um hopefully the cogs are now turning
and you're thinking okay
which form is it gonna be i think it's
gonna be dv
on dt that's got the v that i need to
integrate with respect to because
there's v's on the right hand side
and then it's got a time variable which
when i integrate t will appear and then
off i go
all right so again um if you chose some
other form for acceleration not dv on dt
um i haven't done my homework to try all
those other kinds of approaches but you
need the t
in there somewhere right and if i were
to choose i mean the other form for
acceleration
that has time involved is um the second
derivative
of um oh i should have had a y up there
shouldn't i
um the second derivative of displacement
um but i don't i don't have displacement
over here i don't have any y's so
that's going to fairly quickly imagine
hit a dead end
all right so now i've kind of set up and
the rest of this is going to be the kind
of well the algebra suit that mrs lee's
referred to earlier
so uh what happens well on this next
line here um you can see what i've done
is i've done the separation and variable
step that i've
done so very many times before when you
have a look at this line here
i'm going to integrate shortly but just
before i do you can see there's just a
teeny little of adjustment that i can
make to make this easier
to integrate over here on the left hand
side
you've got something that looks an awful
lot like a
f dash on f situation but if 50 minus v
is my f then f dash should be
negative 1 right because i get that from
the negative v
so therefore to fix that up i'm going to
multiply both sides by negative 1
like so and now i'm good to go this is
ready to integrate so i'm going to
integrate the left and i'm going to
integrate the right it's just going to
give me a log over here
and a this is going to be a linear
function
over here so this is what i landed on
i hope this is looking okay to you this
is
my log of f that came from my f dash on
f and that's a fairly straightforward
result and now i've got a constant
bit cheeky i mean this is a continuation
from my previous question so i probably
should have called this constant two
and called the other one constant one um
but thankfully unlike in some other
questions where you have to integrate
like four or five or six times
just a couple so i i'm gonna be a bit
naughty and leave that there
okay so now i have to find the concept
of integration
okay as we've done before i'm going to
use initial conditions but just remember
we've got whole a whole different set of
initial conditions than um we did
earlier so i initially am setting see
daisy
i'm initially setting the maximum height
up there as
the origin and my velocity is zero so
this is t equals zero and you can see
here i'm going to take advantage of this
v equals zero to
evaluate the v and the t that'll give me
my constant
okay so what do i get uh let's do this a
bit gradually so
you can see here um what am i going to
get you're putting in your v
equals 0 here so that leaves you with a
log 50 on the left-hand side
and then your t equals zero here makes
that t term
vanish so that just gives me a
straightforward c equals log 50.
and when i substitute that back in i do
just a teeny bit of um
you can do i can you can see i do the
same kind of
um log manipulation that i did before um
to make
t the subject because that's what i'm
trying to solve for right so you can see
here
um i've got this in here i've got 50
minus v
i've i've actually sort of taken um well
i've reframed this as an exponential
equation right
so e to the power of log 50 minus v is
just
50 minus v and then i've got e to the
power of everything on the right hand
side here
and so that log manipulation that i did
earlier what it looks like now is
index laws right so you can see here
this uh
one exponent i can break into two so
i'm going to write that as um e to the
fifth t e to the log 50 and as i just
mentioned before
um e to the power of log k
is just k um i might as well i've got
the time luxury of time here so might as
well just
write that in there as a um something to
highlight
it's a fairly easy rule to prove just
using some index and log laws
so once you've got that because e to the
log 50 is just 50
you can see i'm going to end up with
this 50 minus v
hasn't changed on the left hand side but
this turns into that coefficient of 50
at the front there and so where do we
land
i've now got v sort of i'm tidying it up
i'm trying to get
it as a function of time